young entrepreneur asks would you ever
automate your position delegate to as
many people as it takes and spend 95% of
your time fully engaged in family and
life absolutely not this young
entrepreneur young entrepreneur let me
tell you something from old entrepreneur
which is I love the process of the work
I love the grind
I love the climb you know I love the
idea of getting to buying the Jets more
so than buying the Jets it's the process
to delegate out what I love would defeat
the purpose of course I want to spend as
much time with my family as possible but
that would be lying to my soul if I
didn't do what I want to do and what I
want to do for a living is build
organizations build companies create
commerce be a Salesman be a guidance
counselor HR character social
commentator and put out content I would
suffocate if I couldn't put out the work
that's needed to accomplish the things
that I want the problem young
entrepreneur especially when you're a
young entrepreneurs people want stuff
right they want the bling bling here
right they want the cool ass kicks they
want the car they want the jet nothing
Jets they want stuff I don't want stuff
I want the sweat and the pain and the
gratitude and the you know happiness
that comes along with the work I want
the work I don't want the stuff